so some of you have rightly and
accurately pointed out to me that
suddenly florida's coronavirus cases
have started to decline
california's coronavirus cases don't
seem to be spiking the way the
trajectory suggested
and i started to look into this and
indeed it is true if you look at
florida their cases have started to drop
off
but it just so happens that florida
stopped testing this is no conspiracy
theory this is what they announced they
were going to do
because of the hurricane hurricane
isaias
as donald trump has struggled to say uh
look at this article from npr from july
29th
saying florida will pause coronavirus
testing due to impending storm
now it didn't happen all at once in all
of the counties so
we are still seeing thousands of cases a
day from florida but because different
counties
as the hurricane worked its way through
the state stopped testing
the numbers of tests went down
dramatically
and we can sort of turn to donald
trump's favorite phrase here
if you don't test you don't find cases
and that's true
the article saying quote after the
state's testing sites close
thursday evening that's last thursday
they won't reopen
until at least tuesday morning that's
yesterday that's according to candy sims
of the florida
department of health in broward county
so what do we do well one thing we can
look at is icu usage and you can see
that florida icu usage hit 100 percent
in the last week of july and it's still
there you can actually go over 100
percent
in that you can start to convert non-icu
spaces
in hospitals to temporary icu but they
florida has been stuck
at 100 icu usage for days
this is very very bad and i'm getting
more and more people saying
can we even trust the numbers now can we
trust the case numbers
can we even trust the death numbers
right now
and this is a real concern now part of
the concern
generally comes from the change that
happened from july 15th
into july 16th where hospitals were
mandated to stop reporting directly to
the cdc
and instead to the department of health
and human services
there are open questions as to if and to
what degree
that has influenced numbers in specific
states though
we know why the case numbers are going
down florida's one example
they stopped testing because of the
hurricane
let's look at california california now
is admitting that for days they've been
under reporting case numbers the
explanation is still not totally clear
and maybe by later today or tomorrow
we will know more about it but a message
appeared on california's covet 19
dashboard which said quote
due to the issues with the state's
electronic laboratory system
these data represent an under reporting
of actual positive cases
california's top health official dr mark
galley
said quote over the past few days the
state system we've discovered some
discrepancies so we're still waiting on
more information but
when you look at the globe the national
case numbers and you see that they seem
to at least have stopped increasing
understand that two of the major case
centers florida
and california are under reporting cases
one because they are
there they have stopped testing because
of a weather event california for some
unknown reason that they've discovered
discrepancies
and yet even with florida reducing
testing
even with california under reporting we
still had 54
000 new cases yesterday we still had
almost 49 000 new cases on monday so a
few different
thoughts on this cases aren't really
declining they've kind of leveled off at
the national level
but two states are under reporting and
that would be a huge piece of why that
is
so first off at this point it's very
hard to say for sure
whether cases are still growing
nationally or have leveled off or what's
going on
what we do know is that the big picture
the sort of fundamentals of what's
happening in the country haven't really
changed
so we wouldn't really expect a huge
decline because there haven't been any
big changes in policy now it's
conceivable
that even without states really changing
policy
that people are seeing the headlines and
they're being more cautious
that's possible it would take about 15
or so days
to notice that and increasingly deaths
are going to be the indicator to the
extent that we can trust them and if you
look at the trend line in terms of
deaths
the seven day moving average which sort
of smooths out those dips
of reporting that happen over the
weekend the death ra
rate and the death trends don't look
good they may have
maybe leveled off slightly but yesterday
again we had nearly 1500 deaths
so it's too early to say and then you
get to
are there ways to cover up deaths we
know that there are
you can mess with cause of death you can
do other other things so
the important message i think is
we're in an area now where there is a
question mark
around the accuracy of the data we don't
have to go conspiratorial we don't have
to make any definitive statements we can
just say
there are reasons to be skeptical of the
data including
that florida stop testing in california
is under reporting
so we are still at huge risk of even
bigger spikes when the united states
got from what was it 35 000 cases a day
down to 20 000
almost every state started reopening 20
000 cases we still had
and many states saw that as a license to
open and we got all the way back up to
70 000 cases a day
at one point about 10 days ago what we
can say for sure is
widespread reopening and ignoring risk
factors and risky activities and not
wearing masks
is going to create a completely out of
control spike
and just look at some of the headlines
from the last 24 hours teachers returned
to a georgia school district last week
260 employees have already gone home to
quarantine
not good uh dr fauci says if we don't
get below 10
000 cases a day before the fall we will
have an even more insane explosion in
the fall
and that's still 10 000 cases a day that
would mean we needed like an 80 to 90
reduction to get down to 10 000 cases a
day
clorox announces it will not have enough
disinfecting wipes
until 2021 according to its ceo
25 people have been infected at a bible
camp
in oregon when coronavirus subsided in
israel israel reopened schools it didn't
go well
and things are shutting back down this
is a real thing you know when trump says
it's the invisible enemy
it's this dumb thing he keeps repeating
the invisible scourge nobody telling him
it's pronounced
scourge okay but in a sense it can feel
as though it's not really there because
it is invisible
we see the results through our actions
our actions directly
impact these numbers to the extent that
we get the real numbers
and we need to be very cautious you know
i'm trying to take it in stride in the
sense that
my i can only focus on my sphere of
influence i can't control what everybody
in the country does i can't control what
the policy is
i can ensure that i'm acting as
responsibly as possible and at least to
you i communicate what seems to be
responsible
our actions have consequences and if
it's uh
i can't think of a time where it's been
more clear than it is right now
i'm really excited that uh one of our
sponsors today is
helix sleep i sleep on a helix mattress
at home i absolutely love it and that's
why
i reached out to them about sponsoring
the david pakman show
buying a mattress in the past was always
a huge guessing game for me
i didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like but
helix has a sleep quiz on their website
you tell them your body type your
sleeping position
your back pain issues you might have and
their
tool matched me with a mattress that is
perfect
for me it's cool enough at night it's
the right firmness
i generally just do way better sleeping
these days because of the mattress helix
was awarded
number one best overall mattress for the
last two years
by both gq and wired magazine it is well
deserved i can tell you firsthand
every helix mattress comes with a 10
year
warranty you can try the mattress risk
free for 100 nights and they will even
come pick it up at your house
if you don't love it but i know you will
all of my viewers will get up to 200
off your order and you'll get two super
premium pillows
for free when you go to the link right
underneath this video